Both these algorithms it turns out
have been used in the sequential games
setting, the games.
>> Most solution concepts are usually
useful in all those things.
You should mention one other thing
which is we actually pointed out
that something that we talked about last
time was in fact a solution concept.
But Nash.
>> Nash and?
>> Subgame perfect.
>> Right.
Right, by the way worth pointing out.
That the King Solomon alternative.
That I described before
is subgame perfect.
>> All right.
Well so let's flip over to that.
Which is mechanism design.
We talked about.
>> Two things in particular.
We talked about peer teaching.
>> Right.
>> And we talked about King Solomon.
>> Dividing up babies.
>> Baby division.
Never ever divide by zero.
Now what's interesting about mechanism
design, sort of the flip side or
compliment of what we normally think
about in playing games is that one could
look at a lot of these solution concepts
as in fact being mechanism design.
Right, you create coco values as
a way of encouraging certain kinds of
behavior by setting up
binding side payments.
You think of correlated equilibria
as working because you've created
a mechanism, this shared source of
randomization that will encourage
behavior that it wouldn't
otherwise encourage.
Therefore all the solution concepts
can be thought of, sort of,
at least all the ones beyond the kind of
obvious when the natural delivery in any
way I think about that, can be thought
of as a kind of mechanism design.
These extensions,
these things that we introduce are to
induce certain kinds of behavior.
And so, even if we didn't want to
think too hard about mechanism design,
I wanted to believe it wasn't really
a part of reinforcement learning.
It really is, because all of these
things that we come up with as these
sort of extensions solution concepts are
really about getting better outcomes.
>> And they're all about
driving behavior using rewards.
>> Right, which is so
much better than Driving Ms. Daisy.
So I think that's everything
that we've learned.
Okay, so what's next.
>> I think we're done
actually with the material.
We have kind of a wrap up that
we need to do like an outtro and
so yes we're getting down to
the to the near terminal state.
>> Nice.
Well I think it's good well this is been
fun I mean I guess I will get to see you
again after this because we do have
a few things that we need to do, but
I think we've covered all the material.
>> Wow.
Well done.
Great.
Well, good job everybody.
Yeah good job,
I guess I will see you later Michael.
Bye
>> Bye.